Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I am Farren Cousins sitting in for David Pakman
today. If you want more from me, you can find me
on YouTube at YouTube.com slash of the Ring of
Fire. I also have my other channel, YouTube.com
slash. Fair and balanced. And I'm on Twitter,
Facebook, Instagram, and TikTok at fair and
Balanced. Now, I want to end in this last
segment with a couple of interesting stories from
throughout the week that I felt needed a little
bit more exposure. Now, to begin the show today,
I talked about the fact that Alvin Bragg has sued
Jim Jordan to stop the subpoena that he issued
against Mark Pomeranz. Now, what I didn't mention
about that lawsuit was that contained within
the lawsuit. Bragg The Manhattan DA's office,
outlined the threats, the racist threats that
Bragg has received since the indictments were
announced. According to the report, the DA's
office received more than 1000 calls and emails
from Trump supporters since March 18th, the day
when Trump inaccurately predicted his own arrest.
Many of those messages have been, quote, overtly
racist and anti-Semitic. Some were read one of
them here. I'm going to censor some of
this stuff because it's not appropriate.
Hey, George Sorace a whole puppet. If you want
President Trump, come and get me. Remember,
we are everywhere and we have guns. Another one
referred to Alvin Bragg, the first black man ever
elected as top prosecutor in New York. Called him
black trash. One of them called him AIDS infested.
And here's the thing. I have talked
repeatedly on my channels about the
fact that it's only a matter of time before
these threats turn into material action.
But it turns out, as Bragg revealed, that's
already happened. Let me read this from Vice.
Bragg received an envelope containing white
powder and a specific death threat against
him. The letter was immediately contained to
prevent exposure and was later determined to
contain no dangerous substance. According to
a letter Bragg later circulated to his staff.
So you had an angry Trump supporter send a letter
saying, you know, basically, I want you dead.
And the letter contained a white powder. The white
powder, of course, was obviously meant to scare
them because luckily this Trump supporter couldn't
get their hands on anything actually dangerous.
That doesn't change the nature of the threat.
They believed at the time it was real. They
almost have to believe that it's real. Every time
this comes in and this is what happens, this is
what I believe personally Trump wants to happen.
That's why he's been out there attacking Bragg.
He has called him an animal. He has
called him a pervert, a lunatic, a maniac.
Those are all words that Trump has used just in
the last week to describe to describe Alvin Bragg,
to describe Judge Martin. Donald Trump
has gone after Judge Merchant's family.
Are these attacks from Trump on? These
individuals have to stop. And the only
way you can stop that is for Judge
Marchant to put a gag order in place.
Not that I think that would stop Trump, but if you
violate the gag order, the judge in the issuing
has to say a single violation is a night in jail.
Like every time you violate this, every time you
send out a tweet that's an attack on one of these
people, you're going to jail for a night. So if
you send out a post on Truth social with three
different attacks, that's three nights in jail.
That's what the judge could do. That's what
the judge should do to protect these people,
to protect Alvin Bragg, to protect himself and his
family. But the judge had said in the order. Well,
not necessarily in the order, but in the court
discussions Last week during the arraignment,
the judge said, look, a gag order is is
a far off thing. I don't want to do it.
He urged Trump's lawyers to, you know,
tone it down to rein them in. And clearly,
they failed to do that because I don't think
they want to do it. And even if they wanted to,
they're dealing with a client that's not going
to listen to them. So the only possible option
here is the judge to put that gag order in
place. People's lives could be at stake.
I mean, Trump posted the picture of him with the
baseball bat and then Alan Bragg on the other side
of it looking like he was going to hit him. That's
not okay. That is violent imagery that his base
sees. And they think, oh, okay, this is what he
wants me to do. That is how those people operate.
Trump doesn't have to do the damage. Trump doesn't
have to be the one out there getting violent.
Because he knows that if he just says
a couple of buzz words to his base,
shows them a couple of pictures,
they'll take it from there. And I firmly believe
personally that that's got to be what Trump wants